hi guys it's video and today we have the
m1 ipad air 202 this is the 256 gig
model and it has the m1 chip yes that m1
chip found in the new max with eight
cars and eight gigs of ram ipad fifth
gen right here and
we are running the 256 gig model over
here
with that out of the way we're going to
run it through the gauntlet genjin pubg
mobile mobile legends call of duty and
apex legends so that's going to run
through genchin because i'm damn weak
sauce and have not hit in nazumi yet and
i'll be running through the rest so
claire
hi it's claire today i'm going to be
playing genjin in seoul xinhu because
he's not in inno zuma yet so first let's
check the temperature of our ipad
okay so it's 28 degrees it's quite like
it's okay it's even cold even
okay so let's go into genjin and let's
see how the m1 ipad air 2022
runs
[Music]
[Music]
right so now we're in genji and let's
check our graphic settings
okay so for graphics we've put
everything on high or highest
and today we'll be playing at 120 frames
per second
okay so the gantry graphics on the m1
ipad are really really crispy i like
if i play it at this frame rate on my
usual ipad the ipad air 2020 i think
there would be frame pauses every other
second oh look at diana she's so cute
look at that animation it's so smooth um
looking at the inner zuma scenery right
now everything is in clear render and
it's beautiful color
okay so let's get to it let's fight our
thunder manifestation
i haven't played um i haven't played
against on the manifestation until
since i
finally ascended bao so this is going to
be a little rough
let's go diana
go
she was up
in the
apple in apple's ad for the ipad we see
them playing with a full electro team so
i'm really wondering which person
um you know looked at it it was like
yeah this is gonna be a super cool ad
when it really tells us that you know
they've never played i've had it before
i've can see before in their lives
oh no can you
oh something like two of them now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
two casualties
so after that hot fight let's see how
the ipad is doing
okay so 32.4 degrees celsius at this
corner this one
34.2
sun
31 degrees okay
last corner 30 degrees and in the center
it's so nice 31 degrees okay
so there was a bit of change from
earlier
but it's still running fine
so if you're looking for an ipad that
can handle your graphic intensive games
like genjin you might want to invest in
this year's m1 ipad air 2022 and so just
for the memes we will be playing right
on shogun against the thunder
manifestation let's go
it's gonna be so bad yeah
okay let's go on our first strike
immune
[Laughter]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
[Laughter]
here at geek culture we love our
keyboards especially with the all-new
logitech mx keys mini an elegant and
functional keyboard its ultra responsive
rounded keycaps are super stable and
quiet for more productivity there are
buttons to enable dictation microphone
audio control and emojis the backlit
keys illuminate when you get close and
matches the lighting of the environment
you're in it lasts up to 10 days on a
full charge or 5 months with the
backlights turned off to find out more
about the logitech mx keys mini and
their latest range of products head over
to logitech.com to no surprise the ipad
air can handle genjin pretty damn well
so let's just do a quick temperature
check again
we are at about
oh it's really chilly right now about 24
ish
yeah we're at 24 degrees ish down here
so that's fine and with that we'll go
into pubg mobile
extremely fast boot up time to no
surprise honestly and just i think you
guys know i've already set up all the
settings so i don't have to restart
anything so let's just go check what we
have
settings and then graphics
all right
ultra hd ultra frame rate realistic
enabled and the listing is off
shadows are enabled
and yeah
let's get into the game
all right with the settings out of the
way let's just go straight into a game
okay with this 10.9 inch retina display
you know things are looking really good
the game is handling really smoothly as
expected i mean there's a little frame
starter there but honestly nothing to be
worried about
and let's just have a look yeah it's as
pubg as it's gonna get to be honest so
let's just wait and
jump in
ah
very fun
very fun
[Applause]
yeah graphically so far like from what
i'm looking at you know it looks really
good the sunlight is bouncing off the
c130 pretty well
and even the map itself looks pretty
alright
so let's just see how it goes
when we get into a firefight
so far so good honestly not noticing
anything at all
okay
you know what
it'll be fine let's get in
weapon weapon weapon
come on pick up
there you go
okay good good we're good
oh boy come on
oh boy come on ah come on
okay there we go
oh my gosh okay now it's okay first game
you need a little warm-up change up
there you go
two kills not bad
[Applause]
there you are
oh come on
damn it
fine oh gosh
hold up
get screwed my guy
get screwed
i see him
there you go
somewhere along the ridge
oh yes please
okay good i'm happy with an m14
oh very nice there's still one more guy
left
before i wrap this up
oh and then i see him i see him
okay there we go i think got it did i
get it
[Applause]
oh i did yeah last kill
very nice
let's see how this works out
temperature wise
yeah nice
i'd say about
yeah it's about 30 degrees on average
you know which honestly isn't too bad
so yeah let's pop g let's move on to the
next game all right with pubg out of the
way let's just do a quick check it's
about
28 degrees on average
okay that's fine so let's move on to
mobile legends
[Music]
very quick load time and let's just move
on to a game
but before that let's check the settings
and everything's on ultra as i've said
before i've already reset everything so
all of these graphical changes have
taken effect so let's just go straight
into a game
of course
all right let's see how long it takes to
load
welcome to mobile legends
[Applause]
yep there we go
let's go
[Applause]
monsters
let's get this going
okay
[Applause]
very nice
[Applause]
don't bully me
legendary
yeah my nano
don't bully me
legendary
yeah my no no
apple pies are the best things
under attack
[Music]
mama told me not to judge others
[Applause]
killing spree
[Applause]
an ally has been slain
[Applause]
daniel can destroy the turret
do you hate nana
there we go
oh
[Applause]
50 minute game my hands still feel cool
as heck
the ipad doesn't feel hot at all
let's just see what's going on with you
still about 39 degrees 28 degrees let's
see
yeah about 20 oh 30 down here
yeah let's just say it's about 30
degrees celsius right now but honestly
it feels really good to hold it's not
that warm or rather it's not even warm
at all
so this is great
let's move on to the next game
alright with ml out of the way let's go
into call of duty
lightning fast low time as expected
let's go into the settings real quick
all right because we want to push the
ipad air to its limits
graphic quality can be very high frame
is gonna be very high
and multiplayer everything is gonna be
on so we're honestly just gonna push it
all the way up and let's get into a game
very quick little time as expected yeah
wow okay it looks really good the
detailing on my hollow side looks really
great the sun is bouncing off really
nicely here as you can see
and yeah let's get some frags
[Applause]
yeah it handles really smoothly and the
thing is honestly even though the screen
is wide i can see everything and with
the ui like this you know it's really
comfortable to play on
[Applause]
down
[Applause]
targets
[Applause]
reload
and we won
quick game everything feels pretty good
and this honestly this is how most games
should be handled
oh thank you
all right with the game over you know
this is how long every game should run
because you know it's hot and fast let's
just do a quick temperature check
right now it's about 29 on the top in
the mids it's about yeah it's about the
same i guess it's safe to say it's about
29 degrees celsius on average all this
not really no issues with this thing so
with that out of the way let's move on
to
apex legends
all right here we go
fortune
glory
and fame can be yours
if you have what it takes
it's fast
lightning fast as usual let's go
okay we got extreme hd we got extremely
high frame rate that the smoothing is on
everything else here is on as well let's
just jump into a game
so
[Applause]
i mean obviously with the apex they kind
of do like a pre-loading type thing
while you guys are in the character
scene that's why everything's pretty
fast but you know we're still gonna be
putting up the time to load from this
screen all the way up to the point we're
gonna jump or rather at the point we're
in the chip
public enemy number
[Applause]
one very fast okay am i the jump master
i am no i'm not
[Applause]
it's gonna be a lot of heat
still
[Applause]
not the best but it was ideal set up but
you know
gotta work with what we have okay [ __ ]
okay that guy is lagging like crazy
[Applause]
oh man okay
that's great
that's really great so after like four
minutes of gameplay i mean i know it
isn't much but you know let's just see
real quick
still about 29-ish 28-ish oh it's about
like
31 somewhere around here yep right here
k-132
but it still feels very chill it's not
overheating or anything it doesn't feel
warm at all
so let's just go into another game and
let's see how long we can go
reloading
[Applause]
reloading reloading down
[Applause]
very nice reloading
okay let's just create a g7 how did this
work out
okay
now okay we need to go down
[Applause]
nice
[Applause]
it's like hockey
[Applause]
give me a sec recharging sheets
[Applause]
there we go
[Applause]
yeah while things are chill let's just
do a quick temperature check
about 32 36 around here somewhere
but you know what
it's not really heating up that much
doesn't feel that warm
maybe it's a little bit but honestly
something i would think about
[Applause]
heads up dropping the pain
[Applause]
[Applause]
you're loading
[Applause]
very nice
[Applause]
[Applause]
know other than the latency issues you
know this game runs pretty smooth
it's a slight stutter at the menu but
other than that you know this thing is
it's great
hopefully we win the match but you know
what it doesn't matter because we have
an m1 ipad air anyway final temperature
check
we've gone through about how long has it
been
after like two hours and 45 minutes of
playing games you know this thing really
hasn't peaked as much as apex down here
still about like 37 is 38.7 around there
but everywhere else is still in the
green
all i have to say is the apple did
itself a huge favor by putting the m1
chip into the ipad because it honestly
just speaks for itself performance wise
and everything there's
there has literally been no issues with
all the games we played over 2 hours and
45 minutes you know all i would say is
that if you want a dedicated gaming
device for yourself this ipad air 202
with the m1 chip inside this is the ipad
for you
anyway if you guys have any questions
about the m1 ipad air leave them in the
comment section down below i'll do my
best to get back to you don't forget to
follow us on all of our socials like
this video and subscribe to us it helps
us out a lot we have a lot of content
coming your way anyway this is inio
signing off and i'll see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
you